якщо ми думаємо про майбутнє Ми не
можемо платити на дитину 860 грн на
місяць 860 грн на місяць як можна
отримати дитину до трьох років з 860 грн
на місяць або в нас є ну такі речі
взагалі неймовірні коли доплата інваліду
самотньому на догляд 50 грн на місяць 50
скажіть мені що таке сьогодні 50 грн на
місяць або коли йде про пораненого
виведеного поза штат ми говоримо про
військо і ці люди отримують 600 700 грн
на місяць тож ми маємо зробити і
виконати важливе завдання маємо з одного
боку дати гроші на армію але з іншого
боку ми маємо обов'язково хоча б дати
вижити цим людям бо неможливо вижити на
600 грн неможливо вижити на 800 грн на
місяць це просто неможливо